Internships may not always seem like the most
exciting way to start a career but even celebrities
have used interning as a stepping stone to
become a major star.
Whether it be through family connections,
university networking, or pure determination,
these 10 celebrities paid their dues.
Here are 10 Successful Stars who Started out
as Interns.
After you hear our list, let us know what
you think in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to the Screen Rant channel.
Aubrey Plaza
Aubrey Plaza’s disinterested demeanor for
which she is best known, may be ideal for
her comedic styling but for her time as an
intern for multiple companies, her unique
personality was met with varying results.
One of her first internships was for Post-Its
which required her to do menial tasks such
as wallpapering an entire bathroom with the
sticky notes.
Plaza was also given internships related to
her chosen career field.
Along with working as an assistant for short
films, and as an intern for the comedy troupe
The Upright Citizen’s Brigade, Plaza was
also given a job as an NBC page and spent
much of her time on the Saturday Night Live
stage where her future Parks and Recreation
co-star Amy Poehler had the privilege of seeing
Plaza in action.
In a 2006 episode of 30 Rock, Plaza played
an NBC page, which allowed her to combine
her behind the scenes gig with her acting
aspirations.
Steven Spielberg
Steven Spielberg is a film industry icon who
has directed some of the most beloved films
in the last four decades.
Accomplishing such success relied heavily
on his own dedication and passion for the
film industry and the magic of movies.
After being rejected from USC film school
but before dropping out of California State
University, Long Beach, Spielberg was given
an internship at Universal Studios.
After he was no longer a student and had completed
his own short film, he continued to find ways
to sneak into the studio lot and held a position
that was not exactly an official internship
which allowed him to gain access to watch
filmmakers in action.
His time at Universal enabled him to get his
short film “Amblin” viewed by the studio
vice president which scored him a directing
contract.
Oprah Winfrey
Oprah Winfrey is one of the most powerful
celebrities in history, but she wasn’t always
the media mogul she is today.
Even Oprah had to pay her dues by being an
intern.
After college, she started her career in broadcasting
interning for a CBS affiliate in Nashville.
The internship didn’t last long as she was
promoted to news anchor.
She was the youngest and first African American
news anchor for WLAC-TV.
She went from one news job to the next, and
scored her first talk show with 1978’s People
are Talking.
Eight years later, she landed her very own
show, The Oprah Winfrey Show, which made her
a household name.
Anderson Cooper
For what may be the most impressive internship
on the list, Anderson Cooper scored an unpaid
position for the CIA for two summers during
college.
One can assume that with a writer father and
a fashion designer and heiress Gloria Vanderbilt
as a mother, networking was probably not much
of an issue for the CNN journalist.
During his time as a student at Yale University,
Cooper interned for the government agency.
As enticing as taking a position at the Central
Intelligence Agency after college may have
been, Anderson decided to become a journalist
instead stating he was a news junkie his entire
life and would be much more adept to working
in the newsroom instead of being employed
by the federal government.
After more than two decades of success as
an award-winning journalist, Anderson obviously
made a wise decision.
Mindy Kaling
Before Mindy Kaling headlined her own television
show and became a New York Time’s Bestselling
author, she was an intern for Late Night with
Conan O’Brien.
As a nineteen-year-old college sophomore,
she was thrilled to have scored what she believed
was a glamorous internship with one of her
comedy idols.
However, Kaling wasn’t exactly the best
intern as she wasn’t completely willing
to complete the tasks assigned to her.
Rather than doing the basic duties of an intern
such as filing and photocopying, the actress
did her best to follow O’Brien around to
see him in action.
Working with her hero was much more important
to her and she found everything else to be
a waste of time.
Luckily, her career did not depend on the
success of her short time at Late Night.
After college, Kaling and her roommate did
their own comedy writing by composing the
stage play, “Matt and Ben”, which led
to a staff writing job on The Office.
Not too bad for a less than stellar intern.
John Krasinski
Mindy Kaling isn’t the only alum from The
Office who started out as an intern for Conan
O’Brien.
However, John Krasinski was given much more
to do during his time as an unpaid worker.
During his summer break from Brown University,
the future Jim Halpert worked as a script
intern for Late Night.
Krasinski has stated that his time at the
funnyman’s show was an invaluable experience.
He was able to parlay his intern skills as
not only a successful comedic and dramatic
actor in film and television but also as a
screenwriter for films such as Promised Land
and the film adaptation of David Foster Wallace’s
short story collection, Brief Interviews with
Hideous Men.
Diddy
Puff Daddy, P. Diddy, and Diddy are just a
few of the names Sean Combs has been known
for but his many titles do not even compare
the to the countless positions and titles
he has obtained in his career.
The rapper, actor, producer, and entrepreneur
among other things, started out as an intern.
After two years attending Howard University,
Combs dropped out of school in favor of an
internship with Uptown Records in New York
City.
The business mogul had a reputation in college
for throwing outlandish and memorable parties
which served him well in the music community.
During his internship, he worked with up and
coming artists like Mary J. Blige.
He was signed on for an official job at Uptown
but was fired not long after, which prompted
him to create his own company, Bad Boy Entertainment.
Tom Hanks
With five Academy Award nominations and two
wins, Tom Hanks has established himself as
a talented actor who has a knack for choosing
the right roles.
Before he proved his dramatic ability, the
1980s were filled with wacky film comedies
and becoming a titular bosom buddy on the
small screen.
In the previous decade, Hanks honed his craft
by working as an intern for the Great Lakes
Theatre Festival in Cleveland, Ohio.
For three years, Hanks did a little bit of
everything to help out the festival including
set design, lighting, and stage management.
With so much of his time allotted for the
festival, Hanks ended up dropping out college
at California State University, Sacramento
in favor of experience.
Obviously, it was the right choice for one
of the biggest movie stars ever.
Donald Glover
Donald Glover may be best known as Troy Barnes
from NBC’s Community or as his rapping stage
name Childish Gambino but the talented writer,
actor and comedian has been plugging away
in the industry for years despite his youth.
While attending New York University, Glover
worked as a summer intern for Comedy Central.
For some, internships can be a performer's
ticket to fame and success but for Glover,
it was NYU’s sketch comedy group Derrick
Comedy which caught the attention of Tina
Fey and resulted in a staff writing job for
30 Rock at the age of 23, which makes this
particular performer’s time as an intern
appear slightly less exciting compared to
the others on our list.
Olivia Munn
Long before Olivia Munn was brandishing her
telekinetic Katana as Psylocke in X-Men Apocalypse
she was an intern at an NBC affiliate for
Tulsa.
After receiving a degree in Journalism from
the University of Oklahoma, Tulsa was only
her first stop as an intern.
In 2004, Munn made her way to Los Angeles
to pursue acting but found an internship with
Fox Sports.
The internship led to a paid reporter job
for the network but even with a background
in journalism, the gig didn’t sit right
with the actress who hated working in live
television.
Preferring to follow her passion rather than
continuing her work as a reporter, Munn segued
toward an acting career by way of direct-to-dvd
films and ultimately found success in major
movies and appropriately enough, HBO’s The
Newsroom.
That was our list.
If you enjoyed the video, don’t forget to
hit the like button.
Were there any celebrities, who started out
as interns, we may have forgotten?
Let us know who we forgot in the comments
and don’t forget to subscribe so you can
watch more videos like this one.